The other 800-pound gorilla in the room produces a fifth of the electricity in the US.
Despite its issues,...
...the climate change conundrum has brought out a huge advantage over fossil fuels.
Nuclear is CO2-free...
...as well as having a possible advantage over some renewable energy sources.
To reproduce the power that one single nuclear power plant makes,...
...we're talking about building 10,000 windmills.
Where are you gonna put 10,000 windmills to replace one nuclear power station?
It's very, very difficult.
And a technical challenge from the standpoint of not only public acceptance but also land use.
Nuclear plants simply don't emit any CO2.
We, I think, in the nuclear field save over a billion tons of CO2 per year.
So we're saving with nuclear considerable amount of CO2.
The more the public knows about what nuclear really is, the more they like it.
And I think the challenge for the industry is getting that story told.
Nuclear power in many ways is hugely safe compared to the fossil fuels.
It doesn't emit greenhouse gases.
The amount of residue that has to be stored afterwards is not in the billions and billions of tons...
...but a tiny, tiny fraction of that.
In the United States we have a program called the Next Generation Nuclear Plant (NGNP),...
...which we're now in the process to do a preconceptual design of such a reactor.